Let us comment on the
results of the study.
Robert Parker predicted that the
1986 Bordeaux wine is very good
to sometimes exceptional.
On the other hand,
Ashenfelter said
that the 1986 Bordeaux
wine is mediocre.
And made the prediction
that the 1989 Bordeaux would
be the wine of the century
and the 1990 Bordeaux
would be even better.
In wine options, the
1989 Bordeaux wine
sold for more than
twice the price of 1986.
And the 1990 Bordeaux wine
sold for even higher prices.
Later, Ashenfelter predicted
that the 2000 and the 2003
Bordeaux wines would be great.
And in this case,
Robert Parker stated
the 2000 is the greatest vintage
Bordeaux has ever produced,
in agreement with Ashenfelter.
So what is the analytics
edge in this case?
What we have developed is
a linear regression model,
a simple but rather
powerful model
for predicting quality of wines.
It only used few
variables and we
have seen that it predicted
wine prices quite well.
In fact, in many
cases it outperformed
wine expert's opinions.
And what is impressive, in
this first introductory lecture
to linear regression, is that
an analytics approach that
uses data to build a model
that improves decision making
is effective in a traditionally
qualitative problem.